(creepy music)
- Horror films don't get much respect.
But while horror has often
been dismissed as lowbrow,
its music has been in-cra-ba.
- Listen to the score from the 2018
horror thriller Bird Box.
(tense music)
Now check this out.
("Polymorphia" by Krzysztof Penderecki)
Hear the similarities?
This experimental
composition was a key part
of The Exorcist, a film that
changed horror music forever.
But what is that sound and
how did it come to influence
the horror films of today?
- Nahre and I are gonna compose a score
for an original scary short.
But first, let's take a
look back at how scary music
has evolved from the silent
era to The Exorcist to today.
- Since there's been
film, there's been horror.
In the silent era, most films
would either have no music
or they would be accompanied
by live musicians
who would play popular or classical tunes.
Only a handful of silent horror films
were accompanied by original scores.
The music written for the 1920 release
of The Cabinet of Dr.
Caligari was described
by one theater runner as
"eligible for citizenship
"in a nightmare country".
The first time a thematic
musical score was written
for a feature-length American talkie
was for the 1933 monster movie King Kong.
Written by composer Max Steiner,
this score utilized
techniques that would go on
to be used in horror films for decades,
such as Mickey Mousing, in which music
matches a character's action
and leitmotifs which are
short recurring musical ideas
that typically signify the presence
of a monster or a villain.
It's a technique John
Williams would later use
in what's likely one of the most memorable
film scores of all time.
(Jaws theme plays)
This two note leitmotif
is perfect not only
for its menacing simplicity
but also for its functionality.
The quicker it gets, the
closer we know the shark is.
(woman screams)
- During Hollywood's
golden age, horror films
and the scores written for
them often lacked subtlety.
The music usually told
the audience what to fear.
- 50s was so big, giant
ants and these aliens
from outer space, where
60s, Psycho kicked it off.
It was personal.
It's a lot of interpersonal drama.
Bernard Herrmann's
score in that is iconic.
(tense music)
(she screams)
- Psycho's shower scene is
one of the earliest examples
of the jump scare and is one
of the most famous examples
of a stinger chord, a common
horror music technique
where musicians sharply attack the chord
to reinforce the moment of surprise.
(suspenseful music)
Hitchcock originally wanted
the shower scene to be silent,
but composer Bernard Herrmann
decided to write a piece
featuring violins playing the
shrieking upward glissando,
which is produced when a
violinist glides their fingers
up or down the strings as they play.
Hitchcock later said that
"33% of the effect of Psycho
"was due to the music".
- I watch a lot of superhero movies.
Sure, the Avengers score is cool,
but I'm not gonna think
of the Avengers score
when I'm kicking butt.
But when I'm scared alone at night,
I think of that horror movie score.
- One reason the stinger chord
has so effectively heightened
terror in horror films
is that they manipulate the
deep-rooted fear centers
in our brains.
- What makes something scary?
Experimental work has
shown is that screams
that are fear-based screams,
they're known to have
a very particular kind
of acoustic signature.
It's called roughness.
And that gives it the kind
of scraggly, fluttery vibe,
whether they're vocalized
sounds or alarm sounds
or other sounds, it's the ones that have
increased roughness feature,
and that's what you interpret
as a listener as fearful.
It could be a guitar string,
it could be a piano sound.
It could be anything.
- Now let's fast forward to the film
that changed horror music
forever, The Exorcist.
William Friedkin's 1973
classic was so terrifying
that it caused audience
members to faint, vomit,
and protest its release.
Some people even thought the
film itself was possessed.
That's partly because of its
unforgettable soundtrack,
which included disturbing
experimental compositions
that went on to shape
the way horror scores
and soundtracks sound, even to this day.
("Polymorphia" by Krzysztof Penderecki)
That's the sound of Krzysztof Penderecki,
the leader of the Polish School
of Avante-Garde Composers
in the 1950s and 60s.
To get this haunting sound,
Penderecki used tools
like sound masses and tone clusters.
- Penderecki's score, I don't
know, it sounds classic.
I love a song that I don't
know when it was composed,
I didn't know if Penderecki
was from the 1700s or now
and I love that it has
this timeless sound to it.
It's timelessly scary, as well.
- So to create a tone cluster,
you basically take a number of pitches
that are a semi-tone apart.
For example, F sharp, G, G sharp.
(plays notes)
These are all tone clusters.
With sound mass, the focus is
more on the effect as a whole,
where we have a clump of pitches
(plays sound mass)
where the specificity
of each note and rhythm
matters less than the texture as a whole.
His use of these compositional
tools defy the classical form
and help take The Exorcist
to a demonic dimension.
- Although Penderecki's music
feels like a horror film,
he didn't write it for the screen.
Much of his experimental work was inspired
by the real-life terrors of World War II.
As a boy in Poland, Penderecki
witnessed the violence
of Nazi's in his hometown of Debica.
Penderecki's music was also used
in another landmark horror film,
Stanley Kubrick's The Shining.
Horror music, horror film.
- I've never seen a real horror film
from start to finish ever, ever.
- [LA] Is this not your cup of tea?
- When I was little, I used to get scared
watching documentaries about ...
You know those documentaries that talk
about haunted houses or whatever?
- Yeah, but that stuff be real, though.
- Do you think that
there's a stereotypical
horror film sound?
- [LA] I think the shrieking violins.
- [Nahre] Stuff in the
higher register like ...
(high notes play)
(he yells)
- [LA] Yeah.
- Or even any dissonant interval.
Dissonance is a common
aspect of horror film music.
One of the most effective
ways to utilize it
is through the tritone,
musical interval composed
of three adjacent whole-tones.
A major third.
(plays major third)
Or a perfect fifth.
(plays perfect fifth)
These are all consonant intervals
where they sit quite
comfortably in the ear.
Let's compare that to a tritone.
(plays tritone)
There's more tension there.
It's a clashing, dissonant
sound that has helped it earn
the name The Devil's Interval in music.
And you can hear it in many horror films,
like during the canoe
scene in Friday the 13th,
where composer Harry
Manfredini repeats two tritones
a half-step apart.
(tense music)
- Another common technique
is to put familiar
or non-threatening music
into a creepy context.
Often, it's little kids
singing children's song.
(haunting music)
Also, quoting religious
music can help set the stage
for films that traffic in the demonic.
Wendy Carlos and Rachel
Elkind used this technique
in the opening of The
Shining, with a recomposition
of Dies Irae, a 13th
century Gregorian chant.
(sinister music)
- Playing instruments in
specific or extreme ways
is another powerful tool
in horror film music.
You'll often hear violins
play sul ponticello,
which means close to the bridge,
combined with tremolo to
produce eerie me-shrul sounds.
Sometimes, simple techniques
can be just as effective
at heightening dread in horror films,
such as using a bassline to
mimic the sound of a heartbeat,
as John Carpenter did in The Thing.
The steady heartbeat gives us a clue
that something menacing is
constantly lurking nearby
and it's coming for the characters.
(heartbeat music)
Say that, just with strings,
there's something about
sustaining a high note.
Like, can you hear that?
That just builds tension
the more you do it.
- True.
- Also really
low things like ...
- Yeah.
- And then you put a cluster.
- Do you want to approach
the me riding the bike
in the hallway in front of the twins?
I'll approach the door.
- Okay.
- Now here's a score that
we made for a horror film
starring Too-sant Morrison
from our fellow PBS series,
America From Scratch.
(eerie music)
- Little pigs, little pigs,
let me come in.
Not by the hair of my chinny-chin-chin.
And I'll huff, and I'll puff,
and I'll blow your house in.
(ax thuds)
(eerie music)
- [Both] Hi.
Come and play with us.
- Monstrum is a new show
from PBS Digital Studios
about monsters, myth, and lore.
This show is written and
hosted by Doctor Emily Zarka,
who has a PhD in literature
with a focus on monsters.
Basically, she's a doctor of monsters.
Head to the link in the
description to check out the show
and find out the origins
of iconic monsters.